Pokemon go developer niantic have  revealed new details about the wildly  popular game as well as its team leaders  at their comic-con panel the three  characters who up until now have just  been silhouettes we're officially  unveiled as spark for Team instinct  blush 14 mystic and Candela for team  Bella objectively the best team John  Hanke chief executive of niantic also  talked about some of the features  niantic are thinking about adding to  Pokemon go while he stressed these were  in no way confirmed he said the team is  considering adding Pokemon centers which  are traditionally where Pokemon get  healed up and stored although he didn't  specify exactly how they would work in  the mobile game Hank he added that  niantic do intends to bring trading to  Pokemon go but first they need to  stabilize the servers let me know what  pokemon go features you're waiting on  and for everything else that matters in  gaming stay tuned to gamespot  you